a dónde vas ahora
a reino unido el peligroso recorrido
para atravesar el canal de la mancha ha
provocado la muerte de decenas de
emigrantes con temperaturas bajo cero
muchos viajan por uno de los corredores
más transitados del mundo hacia el reino
unido pero no todos logran cumplir sus
sueños de una vida mejor algunos mueren
ahogados o congelados francia urgió a
acelerar el desmantelamiento de las
redes criminales que están detrás de
esto le pone responsable excepto del
niño no situación solo pasa la mayor
responsabilidad de esta despreciable
situación están los contrabandistas es
decir los delincuentes que por miles de
euros organizan la trata de personas
desde irak afganistán áfrica asia y
luego hacen venir a esas personas para
bélgica países bajos y francia para
cruzar el canal de la mancha e ir a
reino unido son estos contrabandistas
los que tenemos que combatir se labor
working combat por su parte el primer
ministro británico instó a los socios
europeos de reino unido a cerrar aún más
las fronteras en wii
es importante que aceleremos todas las
medidas contenidas en nuestros proyectos
de ley de fronteras y nacionalidades
para que podamos distinguir entre las
personas que vienen aquí legalmente y
las personas que vienen ilegalmente
también hacemos todo lo que podemos y no
dejamos piedra sin remover para demoler
la propuesta comercial de los
traficantes de personas y las mafias el
régimen traficantes de inmigrantes el
número de emigrantes que viaja en
pequeñas embarcaciones para cruzar el
canal de la mancha ha crecido
drásticamente este año más de 25 mil 700
personas han realizado el peligroso
viaje las autoridades francesas y
británicas han recogido a miles de
personas en ambas costas en las últimas
semanas en decenas de operaciones de
rescate